no matter how much
a certain set of us i think the majority
of us want to move forward with our
lives want to make choices for ourselves
we want to just get out of this non-stop
awful feeling that we're in with covet
and government
government overreach on our lives uh
they're just gonna keep coming so i felt
like we had to cover some of this stuff
um so here's a video of our surgeon
general now this is our same surgeon
general who you may remember two weeks
ago said that rachel levine was the
first female
four-star general whatever the hell it
is that she is uh but of course she's
not a female
she does not have ovaries she is a
biological male who's living as a trans
woman that's just fine right that's just
great more power to her but he called
her a female so i'm a little already
i've got a little red flag
about his decision-making process well
here's the surgeon general talking about
federal vaccine mandates now for small
businesses not just those hundred plus
businesses the small businesses as well
dr murphy if the law survives legal
challenges will the administration be
extending the mandate to smaller
employers with fewer than 100 employers
employees
well martha certainly nothing is off the
table at this moment but the focus right
now is on implementing uh the current
rule that osha put out
nothing's off the table nothing's off
the table we could nuke half the country
we could just do anything nothing is off
the table with these freaks that don't
listen to us no matter how many times we
get everything wrong i don't like this
guy i don't think he's very good at his
job i don't think he's honest or decent
and i don't think he cares about
individual liberty i don't think he
cares about the constitution or anything
else i just want to be very clear i've
got michael here i've got connor here
guys i will never force you to be
injected with anything and if i did
force my employees to be injected with
something to work for me i would not be
a good person right i don't know all of
their health habits do you guys both
brush your teeth you both brush your
teeth this morning right we've never had
breath issues around here uh or i don't
know how much deodorant they put on i
don't know exactly when they go to the
gym or whatever and it's none of my
business if they started not brushing
their teeth and never exercising and
they started smelling and whatever then
i might say them we got a problem here
guys we're in a small studio you smell
like we got an issue but i what business
would it be i am a small business owner
right i have a bunch of employees a
bunch of full-timers bunch of
part-timers we're growing actually we're
going to be hiring more people like
there's a lot of good stuff going on
here imagine how insane it would be if i
as an employer of just it's a job like
this is a job you guys know you're not
slaves right you are free to go did you
know that you could walk out that door
right now i'm not kidding i'm not
kidding um i don't own these people like
they're allowed to make medical
decisions for themselves but the
government is has become the federal
government of the united states has
become the most psychotic evil
totalitarian regime that that would be
almost possible now i i say that with
some hesitation because i do believe
these people can get worse right like of
course they can get worse they always
double down and get worse but the idea
that they would push not only these big
companies okay so find me first of all i
don't think this but i can see how
someone can make an argument all these
big companies there's so many people
there and you've got to vaccinate
okay fine but little companies with
people that are making decisions for
themselves like will you guys make a
commitment if you're if you're vomiting
say in the morning would you perhaps not
come in you'd be okay with that and if
you were puking your brains out he still
wants to come to work but because these
are good workers that i have here you
see but the point is
i don't have dominion over these people
and i promise you guys i will never
force anyone to make any medical
decision to work for me you know if
either one of you came in and you were
pregnant whatever it might be it's none
of my business
it's fine that's just how it is all
right
um but i won't you know if you start
becoming real fat then i got to get rid
of you because that i can't have we're
in a small room here it's enough enough
uh all right so if that isn't enough
just like these ridiculous ridiculous
people
new jersey new jersey governor murphy
this is the democrat who just got
reelected by a hare he almost got
uh taken out a couple days ago in the
election like he just they just missed
it there and new jersey has made their
decision they want to go blue stupid um
so now they've got this guy he's on with
george stephanopoulos talking about when
we could maybe take masks off kids and
yeah you're not going to like the answer
fatigue
everybody has it i think you know it
probably people that abide by the rules
have it uh
considering that that seemed to be a
little bit of a motivator for some are
you at all
thinking about
some relief on any of your mandates
listen there's mandate fatigue
everywhere including with yours truly so
let there be no doubt about that um
at the moment no but my my hope
is particularly with our kids under the
age of 12 that now being able to get the
vaccine that we will at some day sooner
than later be able to lift the mask
mandate that we have in schools
that is my fervent hope we're not there
yet
but please god we can get there sooner
than later we got to get there safely
responsibly but i believe we can get
there and i hope it's sooner than later
it's just perfect he's the perfect
democrat because he's exactly like
fouchy he just says nothing using a lot
of words he hopes we can get there
you know maybe we can get there one day
notice he never gives you numbers we'd
need to see this number so we could do
this even if any of this made sense and
we know that masks don't even make sense
in the first place but congratulations
jersey you voted this guy in so inject
your kids and keep them in masks forever
and by the way the winter's coming and
then they'll tell you oh no
you know we've even got some flu coming
in so we better keep the mass because of
the flu
we'll have more on that in just a second
but it's just like why are you giving
these people power why are you paying
attention to these people i'm hungover
from florida i'm hungover on freedom
right now i saw the promised land i've
been to the promised land in the
everglades
now we've got cdc director rochelle
wolinski this piece of work and now she
just wants masks forever i'm guessing
she's got some money in a mass company
take a look
[Music]
the evidence is clear
mass can help prevent the spread of
covet 19 by reducing your chance of
infection by more than 80
whether it's an infection from the flu
from the coronavirus or even just the
common cold
in combination with other steps like
getting your vaccination hand washing
and keeping physical distance wearing
your mask is an important step you can
take to keep us all healthy
get vaccine fix
we can do this
oh blow it out your ass lady i just
can't is that a phrase did i just make
up that phrase i don't even know if
that's a phrase i i can't deal with
these people anymore because what she's
saying there is masks reduce the chance
you're gonna get sick by 80 but she said
from covid flu and even the common cold
well yes people get the common cold
we've been getting the common cold for
thousands of years people have been
getting the flu for a long time and
usually they survive and you know who
really often survives these things kids
but they want to inject the kids and all
of that nonsense